now chinese leader xi jinping is widely
regarded today as the country's most
powerful leader since mao zedong but one
china watcher predicts that he will soon
be removed from office
we'll talk more about that in a moment
but first a quick overview of the power
she has amassed in november 2012 he was
elected communist party general
secretary and chairman of the party's
central military commission making him
china's paramount leader a few months
later he launched a national
anti-corruption drive which many see as
having been conducted outside the
framework of due process now it's seen
the downfall of hundreds of thousands of
officials and functionaries in 2018 the
national people's congress abolished
term limits for the president and vice
president making she a potentially
lifelong leader
and in 2020 she called anti-monopoly
efforts against online firms one of the
country's chief goals a speech by
alibaba founder jack ma criticizing the
party is said to have infuriated xi
and joining me now in studio is roger
garside a former british diplomat and
long-time china watcher he's also the
author of the book china coup the great
leap to freedom in it mr garcia claims
china is set to transition to democracy
after a successful coup against
president xi jinping welcome to berlin
and to dw news asia roger garcia thank
you
great to be here it's it's quite a
prediction to make a transition to
democracy but before that a coup that
ousts president xi jinping
why do you say that on the basis of what
well three-quarters of the book is
factual one-quarter is semi-fictional
and the three-quarters
says
why
this
dictatorship
which is a totalitarian dictatorship not
an authoritarian regime this
totalitarian dictatorship
is outwardly strong but inwardly weak
and i could run through some of the
weaknesses if you like but then when you
say it's weak you're saying that that is
what is going to lead to a coup so it's
going to be something that will happen
from within the ranks of the communist
party is that what you're saying within
the top ranks of the communist party
um
but
with an external
force acting as well
um the u.s and its allies
have got to adopt a more aggressive
strategy towards china we can't dictate
what how china is governed but we can
and must
engineer
events so that we help those who want to
free china to do so so let me understand
this until the time there is this
external stimulus from
the u.s and allies and the liberal west
is what you're referring to there is no
coup in china is that what you're saying
and you almost seem to sound that you're
laying out a prescription of how
to bring about regime change in china
yes
but it's not a question as i say of
dictating or imposing a change on china
but with working within the forces with
the forces which are within
to achieve a free china um
very recently um the highest level
defector from china to the u.s since
1949
came out and said just what i said
that just what i say in the book which
was written before she ever spoke in
public
she is saying
that based on 15 years teaching ideology
to the senior party carders at the
national
central party school
she believes that 60 to 70 percent of
senior officials of the party
regard constitutional government and
democratic government
as
the best recipe for stability and human
rights defense in china right but i
wonder if they will act the reason i ask
this is because they're they're against
a man president xi jinping who has
declared himself effectively president
for life yeah and uh he is i think the
only leader after mao zedong to have
this much amount of power in china since
2013 when he took over he began a very
popular anti-corruption campaign which
effectively got rid of rivals therefore
i ask you
are these rivals there and are they
going to be able to act
their rivals are there and they
can be enabled and help to act
if we
the liberal democracies adopt the right
strategy and tactics and let me
illustrate i illustrate this in the book
but events have been moving
very much in line with my predictions
since i stopped writing in 2019
u.s congress has adopted
measures which will lead
to a confrontation
between financial markets between
financial regulators
um
between the us and
china
the u.s is
insisting
that chinese companies listed traded in
the us
248 of them
reveal right um share audit information
which the chinese government has always
prohibited them from sharing and when
that law
uh bites in the u.s
there will be a confrontation
of
beginning in the financial field but
will
rapidly become political right quick
last question
when do you see the school happening
well it could happen before november 22
why because that
is the date by which we expect the next
national party congress of the communist
party of china to take place and to
anoint xi jinping for a further five
years
so if these people are to act
then that is an important
deadline
and we leave it there for the time being
thank you so much for joining us here
today roger garside author of chinaku
the great leap to freedom thank you so
much for coming in thank you
you